uh there was a time of persecution and
then after that
um
he went he went to different places he
went to tariff
which is a place outside of mecca he
went to el salvador two clans two tribes
and what it was is that he was he was
trying to get support for his project or
the monotheistic project because he was
being boycotted et cetera he eventually
got it from us
these two tribes because they actually
believed in the religion of islam this
is documented like without a shadow of a
doubt this is what happened and then is
this in the medina is this the medina
period that you're speaking out so this
is actually technically the meccan
period
okay still the meccan period yeah so
right before medina literally was
established because medina is the it was
it was so called after the prophet
because medina just literally means the
city in arabic it was called the
ethereum before and then they changed it
into madina to nebi like the city of the
prophet and so that's why it was kind of
called medina after that
in that time period so you've got 13
years of medina
the vast majority i'm not going to say
all about the vast majority of wars that
took place
and in fact all of the wars that took
place before the conquest of mecca were
defensive so the pagan arabs went to
medina and tried to siege it
and all of these are names of wars in
fact there was according to monschola
there were 19 such wars
in 10 years so that's almost an average
of two wars every year and for me i see
that actually as an evidence for prophet
because the prophet was actually
fighting in these wars he wasn't just
you know throwing people around telling
him to fight for him he was fighting in
them and there were defensive wars
um
so in that time period what happened was
i'll give you one okay so okay so let me
let me interject something there because
that's
that's that's very that's a very hard
thing for me to
to get straight in my mind yes now
um
i would say that and the division in
islam that occurred almost immediately
upon muhammad's death and which has not
been rectified to this day quite the
contrary that's also you know that's a
problem for everyone it's a problem for
muslims it's a problem for christians
it's a problem for everyone and it's a
problem that could really get out of
hand now it's not like i don't know that
the protestants and the catholics were
at each other's throats for you know
hundreds of years so
but that's that's not the issue at the
moment so
now in in islam there's a tremendous
emphasis on christ's doctrines as well
and there isn't any evidence that christ
himself took part in let's say wars
okay so
it's hard
and i mean
what do you mean okay well if you if you
analyze christ as an archetype
when he comes back in his second coming
he is going to dominate the world
and one can say well that's not the
historical christ but when we're when
we're looking at him in the way
look that's a reasonable that's a
reasonable objective
and i understand that a judge a judge
has a judge has that that martial
element and i don't think it's
reasonable to use the archetypal
representation as an argument against
the historical reality and look i'm not
saying to you that i know that what
muhammad did was wrong that isn't what
i'm saying i'm saying that i don't
understand
how
participation in those defense of wars
let's say but then that was also
followed by a tremendous explosion of
islamic expansion right the biggest
empire the world had ever seen in a very
short period of time
right at right at europe's doors
and so
and that was also followed by the
severance of the islamic faith into two
major categories and and interned
conflict there and so there's that that
stream of of
of armed conflict activity i i think
that you're
with respect i i don't think you're
getting the history fully right here
because well
go yep that's fine cool yeah the the the
the war in germany that the wars between
shia and sunnah or what would then be
it's not really between sunnah because
quite frankly shiism had not been
established does it but the the the wars
of the companions how many people died
in those wars
do we have any numbers
for maximum we can say but it's but
fair look fair enough man and it's not
like it's not chris it's not like
christianity hasn't been rife with
internecine conflict yes
but but the fact is is that it was
almost immediately after muhammad's
death that this fracturing took place
among the people that were closely
allied with him and it was a bloody
fracturing and it isn't obvious that
it's been wrapped
how bloody was it well how bloody does
it have to be you know it doesn't take
much
okay
well let's be honest let's be fair yeah
yeah
let's be fair right with with with with
the wars that took place 30 to 40 years
and it wasn't immediately after because
you said that in the video the day he
died that's wrong he didn't happen the
day he died it happened 30 to four years
after
it happened 30 to 40 years after and how
long how how many people how many
members of muhammad's immediate family
survived during that 30 years
my understanding was that most of his
immediate family died in armed conflict
relatively immediate family died in his
own lifetime
yes well i'm not speaking of them but
i'm speaking of what happened after he
died that's right because yeah okay look
first first fact
muhammad
uh salah sallam we say salah meaning
peace and blessings upon him
all of his children died in his life
okay except for one
so most of the members of his immediate
family and his wife died khadija died
his uncle abu talib died his other uncle
hamza died they all died within his
lifetime either due to illness or due to
some other some other cause war for
example like one of the defensive was
hamza died
and by the way muhammad forgave his
killer and that's something which which
goes against the warlord thesis because
when he then conquered mecca
when he conquered mecca he was actually
no fighting i'm not sure if you know
this it's called fat
when he went into and conquered mecca he
didn't fight anybody
it was no fighting there were a few
people that that were exempted but he
actually quoted what joseph quoted to
his brothers in the quran in the quran
which is letter 3 by alaikum that no
blame is on you today and so and this by
the way is a bedrock example of
forgiveness in islam because these were
people that were persecuting him for 13
years these are people that were that
killed his uncle like i said there's one
person called washi
who um who literally killed his uncle
and uh and mutilated his body and he
said
to ashi i forgive you but i can't i
can't see your face because of how
how
he said
he said can you keep your face away from
me because i can't psychologically i
can't bring my faith but i do forgive
you he said so he forgave people that
killed his own family members
and this was after he he himself
attempted a treaty with the pagans
called hodebiya
and so they broke the treaty and that's
what initiated the conquest of mecca
which was
not a conquest that was
fighting now if you compare this because
i think the comparison if there's any
comparison that can be or should be made
it's the it's jesus's second coming with
muhammad in the medinan period not in
the meccan period in the meccan period
both were being persecuted jesus in his
life and muhammad in his in the meccan
period but jesus when he comes back he
will then get authority and he will be i
uh he will be ruling with the iron
scepter according to the bible he would
be crushing his uh
he will be crushing his enemies as it
says in corinthians under his for
humbling his enemies under his foot uh
and killing and violent violent stuff so
in fact
i will actually argue today that the new
testament representation of jesus christ
in his second coming is way more violent
than muhammad's
conquests in the medina okay well look
like i said i wasn't i wasn't trying to
make the case i wasn't trying to make
the case that
what happened in mecca or medina was
wrong like so let me explain that a
little bit
so
christian europe fought a defensive war
against the nazis
it isn't obvious that that was wrong i
don't think that was i wouldn't say
that's defensive
well okay fine but but i understand the
concept of defense of war
america
america when america got involved in
world war ii
it was not under immediate threat by
germany and they colonized it and here's
the thing caught it it overtook western
germany you see and well
here's the thing the term warlord that
you use with the prophet you've never
used with harry truman you've never used
with uh
with uh roosevelt you've never used with
winston churchill all of which conquered
countries literally in wars because i
feel like there is there is a bias there
and you actually never used it with
anybody else aside from the prophet
muhammad in your public output and i
think that's unjustifiable i think that
you have biblical prophets like moses
you have biblical prophets
like um joshua you have you have the
jesus in his second coming all of which
were warrior prophets
and and and and you've only used the
term uh
warlord with the prophet muhammad i
think that is unjustifiable i think if
what is it that caught
what makes someone a warlord in you
then if if it's conquering lands then
harry truman is a warlord then uh
you know and so on and so forth in fact
i guess that's a real that's a real
tough question isn't it what makes a
warlord and what makes it just war it's
not like any of us have the precise
answers to that i think that's what
partly what we're trying to hash out the
definitions of the word warlords the
definition of the word woodward
according to collins is that someone who
acquires force by aggressivity and
violence
and you push back on me so i'll push
back on you to some degree okay well
it's certainly the case that the
expansion of the islamic empire was
accomplished by a tremendous amount of
war-like activity and that wasn't
defensive
now look i understand that monotheism is
a difficult state to attain
and that monotheistic societies have
emerged in the midst of conflict
throughout human society i understand
that and i'm not even saying that
there's something exceptional in that
regard about islam although the rate at
which it happened was quite remarkable
but it still it presents us with a
problem doesn't it
i mean everyone it presents everyone
with a problem
and the problem is well for example the
problem is reconciling the idea of
turning the other cheek with the idea of
a just war a defensive war or an expanse
of war for that matter and of course
that issue is relevant to islam because
islam exploded outward and produced the
biggest empire the world had ever seen
in in the in the space of a few short
centuries
so then well so then you ask well what's
the spirit what is the spirit that
animated that and is that attributable
to the islamic doctrines themselves
i don't know the answer to that now let
me tell you the answer to that okay
and this is what i want to tell you
conclusively and this will help build
bridges honestly because we can maintain
the warlord thesis we can maintain the
expansionist thesis but here's what i'll
tell you
islam has a has a capability to be
expansive
and it also has a capability of making
peace treaties
and it does and it should do whatever is
in his best interest just like every
country should do ever in his best
interest in the pre-modern world we did
not i think this is highly anachronistic
in the pre-modern world there was no
such thing as un it was a realist
international relations framework
whereby everybody was fighting everyone
the roman empire didn't care
about what it didn't care about you
quite frankly it was expanding itself
the persian empire was expanding itself
and the and the arabian peninsula was in
between both and so it could have either
been swallowed by those two other
empires or it could decide to in fact we
will impose our government on them
before they impose it on us and it
decided the former rather than the
latter it decided to expand and in fact
the prophet in his weakest of times he
predicted that that would happen
you know there was one more in
particular where they were they were
starving and it's called khandak and he
hit iraq and he said
the roman empire has been conquered he
hit another iraq again he said forte had
fairest that the persian empire has been
conquered and then he knocked the rock
again he said he said this in his
weakest moment he said that the yemen
has been conquered i see that the
expansion of the islamic empire is a
proof of islam and you know it's not
just me even historians say this how
barnaby rogerson he said the fact that
islam spread
to the roman empire and the persian
empire is equivalent to
the the is equivalent to eskimos taking
over russia and america i believe it's
miraculous if anything that this
happened i don't think it's
unjustifiable i think actually during
peace and to be then
stop it why did it stop at europe's
borders so to speak
if it was the worst
yeah
because of uh
it wasn't successful there it wasn't it
it stopped where it it
couldn't go further but the point is is
that it's not like the christians at
that time in
rome cared i mean they did the same
thing for years they were expanding
themselves well that's why i said that's
why i said i wasn't making a private
fancy case that this was wrong i'm
trying to understand it and so and you
objected to my
use of the term warlord and perhaps
rightly so you know perhaps that was an
injudicious comment i was rather shocked
when i was reading islamic history when
i
encountered the degree of violence that
surrounded these events and so you know
maybe i was like i was appreciative you
said that i think this that shows real
sincerity in it and it's it's one step
closer to creating real
uh meaningful relationships between uh
well i think and i think you're you know
your defense that well the world was a
battleground of empires and you know if
it's if it's push out from our territory
be encroached upon and dominated then it
isn't obvious that being encroached upon
and dominated is the right
approach the correct approach the most
moral approach let's say um especially
because there'd be no shortage of
bloodshed that would also accompany that
so sometimes you're in a bad place and
but you know it's not an easy thing for
any of us to
what would you say mediate between
doctrines like turn the other cheek and
love your enemy and also at the same
time discuss the necessity of both
defensive and sometimes expansive
expansionist wars right we all have to
contend with that and and
and it's very difficult to contend with
it the arguments are extremely
complicated you're absolutely right and
i